Fitbit ushered in the modern day trend
of using wearables to learn about your
own individual health data whether it be
step counting sleep tracking or
continuous glucose monitoring by 2050 I
predict that wearables loaded with
sensors will eliminate the already
dubious annual physical and send most of
our primary care doctors the way of
switchboard operators before the Advent
of continuous glucose monitoring people
with diabetes had to prick their fingers
throughout the day some 540 million
people live with diabetes worldwide a
number that's expected to grow to almost
800 Million by 2045 the global
prevalence of obesity tripled between
1975 and 2016. on one level that's a
free market success story fewer people
are dying of starvation than ever before
they're now experiencing the
consequences of gluttony and abundance
but over the next 27 years we should
expect better drugs and devices
detecting problems earlier and more
accurately than ever before